man:
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Chief Executive
Officer of Google,
Dr. Eric Schmidt.
Schmidt: Thank you.
[applause]
Thank you all.
First let me start
by welcoming everybody.
Many of you traveled
a long distance
to come here
to, uh, spend two days with us
to talk about the thing
I like the most,
which is programming.
And let me tell you
that it's time.
It's time for us
to take advantage
of the amazing opportunity
that is before us.
And that's what I want
to talk about
for just a few minutes.
Today and tomorrow,
you're going to have interesting
product announcements,
some fun stuff,
and perhaps most important,
you're gonna spend time
with the best programmers
in the world
who are here in the room.
Literally you all.
And we're very excited
to have you here.
Uh, from my perspective,
it's time.
We have spent 20 years
trying to build
a programming model
that's the right one.
We started
with the mainframe model.
Then we moved
to the PC model.
And it had brilliant parts
and very frustrating parts.
And then
the internet arrived.
And internet programming.
The way we think
about it now
is something
we have all worked on
for all of our career.
It's time.
Why is it time?
We finally now have
the networks,
the businesses,
the programmers,
the programming tools,
that can build
the kind of platforms
and the kind of opportunities
that I want to highlight.
Today and tomorrow,
you're going to hear a lot
about some
of the Google technologies
many of you,
you--you are already using.
For example,
Google Web--Web Toolkit.
You know, we used
to say "write once,
run anywhere with Java"
back in my old--
in my old job.
Now it's write "write once,
run on any browser," right?
Uh, because the browsers
have become so complicated.
That's what GWT
is all about.
We're going to see
a lot more things
about a product
called App Engine,
which now today includes,
by the way,
support for Java, right,
which is great,
and more,
presumably, coming.
The notion of these platforms
as powerful platforms
are part of a story
that's been true forever.
And it's a story that innovation
always occurs elsewhere.
It never is in the little world
that I sit in
or that you sit in.
It's always somewhere else.
There's always a programmer,
an inventor,
a brilliant person
who's somewhere other than
where you are.
They need to use a platform
that you build.
They need, for example,
to be able to use a platform
even if they don't
speak English
and even if they don't
really understand
some of the other things
that you've done,
but because they have an idea
and they have a vision.
And maybe they use
the wrong operating system
or they have
the wrong background
or whatever,
but they're clever
and they're smart.
And that's
how innovation occurs.
It's always been true
and it will always be true.
And that's why
we're here today.
Maybe you're here
to talk about Android
and some of the things
that we're doing there.
Android looks like it's going
to have a very strong year.
Not only do we have
many thousands
of applications now
as part of our Android
application store,
but we also have
many hardware partners
that are coming along
to build innovative
new hardware platforms
which look like phones,
but do a lot of things
that--that are not
normally associated with phones.
Again, the innovation cycle
continues.
So what we want you to do
is we want you here
to spend your time
with our teams and vice versa
and yourselves
with each other
to try to figure out
what we can do now.
So why is it time?
Why is it time?
Why is it time
to take the challenge?
Because people
are frustrated.
They're tired
of the complexity
of all of the systems
that have been built up
over the last 10, 20 years.
They don't work that well.
Where's the "it works"
option?
Where's the button where it
just installs and works?
Why do we keep adding complexity
after complexity in our--
in our world?
Well, here's an opportunity
using Ajax programming,
the new programming
languages,
the new programming paradigm
that we're going to talk about
in the next couple of days
to build another step higher.
To bring another level
of functionality
that ultimately means power
can generate simplicity
and ultimately
make these systems
simpler and easier to use
by the people we serve
who are not programmers.
They're not computer
scientists.
They're not engineers.
I'm one of these people
who believes
that computer science
is at the center
of the universe.
I'm one of these people
who believes
that what we do as scientists,
as programmers,
as people who care
about making the world
a better place,
can really scale.
I'm a person who believes
that scalability
and the power as r--
as evidenced by the power
of the internet
is just beginning.
And I would tell you
that we're just at the beginning
of getting this right.
When we talk
about cloud computing,
we talk about all
the new kinds of devices,
you're seeing a whole new set
of companies, ideas,
product solutions,
competitors.
All sorts of things all coming
from this shared vision
around a new
programming model.
It's not the old
programming model
where I was handed a book
and said program
against these interfaces
against this standard OS
and everything
will work locally.
But it's a similar model
where I can go pick
the very best
of this code
and that code.
Put it together.
Mash it if you will.
Have it automatically
compiled.
And have it deliver
tremendous performance
for all of us.
With this, we can take
the collective intelligence
of the internet,
which is astounding--
all the information,
all those things going on--
and do amazing things.
We can tell people
what's going to happen.
what's happening nearby.
We can follow
what they care about.
As you walk down the street,
we can tell them the history
of the buildings
as we walk along.
We can do image recognition
to sort of see what's happening.
All of these are applications
that someone in this room
has already built.
All of you are busy building
the version 2
of all of those kinds
of things.
It's phenomenal.
So my message to you
is this is the beginning
of the real win
of cloud computing.
Of the real win
of applications.
of the internet,
which is changing
the computing paradigm--
the one that we've all
grown up with--
so it just works.
It works no matter what device
you're using,
whatever operating system
as long as you're connected--
and even if you're no--
offline with some caching,
you're on and you have
everything you need.
That's the promise
of our new web computing model,
which we're all
talking about.
We're going to show you
some amazing technology
and some amazing partnerships
that we've done
in the next hour and a half.
I'm delighted
that you're here
and I'm excited
about what we're doing.
And I want to take a minute
to thank you for coming
and also introduce
Vic Gundrota,
who's the executive
who's in charge
of all of our develop programs,
all of our mobile programs,
and lots of our businesses.
Vic, can you join me
on stage?
Thank you very much.
Gundrota: Thank you, Eric.
Schmidt: Take care, Vic.
Gundrota: Appreciate it.
Schmidt: Thanks.
Gundrota: Thank you.
Schmidt: Thank you.
[applause]
Gundrota: Thank you for those
opening comments, Eric.
And good morning, everybody.
Welcome to I/O.
Never underestimate the web.
It's a mistake
that I once made.
It was about a half
a decade ago
and I was leading a team
at Microsoft responsible
for driving the developer
adoption of Windows.
Of course we had seen
the emergence of the web.
But we argued that web apps
could never rival desktop apps.
In fact, our favorite
and our canonical example
was from a small Bay Area
company called Keyhole.
Keyhole had made the fan--
most fantastic
geovisualization software
for Windows.
And it was exactly
that kind of software
that we argued
could never be done on the web.
In November of 2004,
Google acquired
that small company
and a few months later
released maps.google.com
with satellite views.
A web app
that simply left us stunned.
Maybe you remember
the first time you
from any browser
were able to zoom down
into your own backyard.
You know, Google Apps--
Google Maps was amazing--
is amazing.
But what was even more important
was what that application
was foretelling.
That we would see
what we formerly thought
was impossible
become possible,
even commonplace
in the browser.
Yes, the web has won.
It has become the dominant
programming model of our time.
In many respects,
this conference, Google I/O,
is about a celebration
of that open web platform.
And this morning,
I'd like to talk to you
about the ongoing evolution
of--of the web.
Of making a more powerful web
made easier.
And this morning's keynote
is broken up
into two broad sections.
In the opening section,
I'm going to show you,
uh, what's making the web
more powerful.
Some new HTML 5 standards
that are enabling us
to build applications
that I think
will surprise users.
And in the second half
of the keynote,
I'm going to highlight
some Google services
that we believe can help you,
uh, build those apps
much easier.
So let's get started here.
Let me find the clicker.
You know, I think when you
look back over the last year--
in fact, just the last
eight, nine months--
you have to be amazed
at the rate our web platform
is accelerating.
It seems like almost
every other month,
we've had a browser released
even--either for the desktop
or for mobile.
And these new browsers
are not just faster--
I mean, of course
they're faster--
but even more importantly,
these browsers are incorporating
.NET new functionality
that, frankly, I'm not sure
most developers know about.